when you look at this right on the face
of it you have a choice okay you could
go in this direction and you can say I
want an a squared minus x squared on the
denominator or you could choose I want a
1 minus something else swear
the answer is live in question is which
one of these two forms are by going
towards ok so I want to practice this
substance you should think so I want to
make that a 1 okay I'm gonna turn that
into a 1 so doing that what factor do I
have to take out I have to take out four
it's under the square root right so that
means it's going to be a 2 on the
outside of the ok again let's say you've
got multiple positive here right so I'm
trying to practice doing it the other
way it's fine but like I said like I'm
choosing simple example seating at one
up here
yeah they're like I said it's not
different yeah there's all these
different ways to go through this okay
like I said in this case and this is one
of the perfect reasons why we're doing
this starting with the inverse trig it's
like I can do this way or this way and
I've got lots of different options and
they'll all work nicely but sometimes
you'll be and I'm gonna show you you'll
be presented with some and it's like
look you have no other choice
you have to go by intervention by
substitution there's no other simple way
to go about this so that's why I'm
trying to I'm trying to flex this class
up a little bit even though you can do
this another way it's a little bit like
you know I'm trying to get you these
your your non-dominant hand to do
something if you like I haven't done it
here I really couldn't using it but
sometimes you'll need to use this hand
sometimes boy okay so here's what I'm
going to do I am going to run around a
pretty good yeah I'm going now if I take
it out my for this is nine on 4x squared
right
and then actually for reasons that will
become clear in a minute I'm resting my
heart over there okay there's nothing
wrong with I mean that that half been
it's a concert coefficient I can relate
on the inside ticket the outside doesn't
matter where it is convenient so in this
case what's the thing that's being
squared it's 3 or 2x right instead of
different regular X so I'm going to
write it in such a way to make that
clear so I'm gonna go one on square root
of 1 minus
okay happy now all right now already
I've made it perfectly fit for this
format I'll show it before so I'm going
to introduce my substitution I'm gonna
say let u equal three onto X therefore I
can use that to change the function of
integrating but how am I going to change
the variable I'm integrating with I'm
gonna need the derivative of this guy
right that's what relates to you and DX
together does that make sense
so that's why at this point I'm saying
to you or DX equals 302 now yes okay at
this point like oh how do I use this
I could I could use this trick that I
did before right saying what's one equal
to because I can substitute one anywhere
I like
however well I can be even a little
cheaper than that you see I have a half
here I've already got a half there
I get substituted for that half it's
really easy to do in this case I divide
both sides by three which is something I
have in my answer but saw might as well
use it
okay so now I'm ready to do my
substitution I've got the function and
then I've got the variable so I'm going
to go one on one - you sweat that half
is gonna become this guy yes and there
was already a DX hanging around prior to
that cancel cancel now everything has
been changed everything's in terms of
use so I can go you plus the constant
and I've heard is that makes it